le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
un programme a vu le jour en 2007 pour
valoriser les hauts de l'île la Réunion
est donc bien accompagnée en termes de
développement avec ce programme appelé
leader qui est un axe à part entière du
fait Ader le Fonds européen pour
l'agriculture et le développement rural
ce programme permet la diversification
de l'agriculture la rénovation des gîtes
de montagne ainsi que la valorisation du
patrimoine
quels sont les personnes bénéficiant du
programme LEADER et quels en sont les
financements on en parle tout de suite
dans lien social
c'est avec près de 28 millions d'euros
de subventions que le programme LEADER a
pu voir le jour avec 60% venant du fait
Ader et 40% de la région et du
département des acteurs locaux sont au
cœur des décisions dans l'attribution
des subventions faibles associations
agriculteurs élus et membre du gaz
groupe d'actions locales les équipes du
gaz s'occupent à la fois de l'animation
des dispositifs de l'instruction
administrative des dossiers et leur
présentation en comité de programmation
ce qui simplifie les démarches pour les
porteurs de projets ces techniciens
assurent ainsi un accompagnement complet
depuis la formalisation du dossier de
demande jusqu'à son examen en comité et
ensuite un suivi de la réalisation du
projet la pépinière Timao a bénéficié de
ce programme et Patrick Rodier et son
épouse nous explique leur choix de
cultiver des plantes endémiques et
indigènes on s'est installé il y a à peu
créer un an et demi deux ans en
pépinière c'est un projet horticole on a
voulu se démarquer un petit peu des
autres et faire quelque chose d'utile
pour la Réunion donc on a décidé de se
lancer dans la production d'indigènes et
dans des mics sont des plantes qui ont
de moins en moins de place dans la
nature donc on est installé sur une
surface de 1000 mètres carrés environ et
on a un petit tunnel de 50 mètres carrés
qui sert à tout ce qui est
multiplication donc tout ce qui est
semi-abouturage les plantes endémiques
c'est des plantes qui poussent qu'à la
Réunion indigènes ça peut être de toute
la zone donc toute la zone mascarène
Maurice Rodrigue madame réunion voilà
c'est pour ça que ces plantes ont un
intérêt un grand intérêt c'est que si on
les si elle disparaisse dans les forêts
elle n'existeront plus du tout nulle
part puisque elle ne pousse qu'à la
réunion nous ça nous tient à cœur de
sauver ces espèces pour que demain les
générations futures connaissent encore
c'est quoi un Corse blanc c'est quoi un
bois de rempart etc là actuellement on
fait aussi un peu de production
horticole classique donc ça pas faire
20% à peu près de notre production on
peut très bien mélanger au niveau
ornemental des plantes endémiques
indigènes à des plantes horticole
classique le tout c'est surtout de pas
utiliser des plantes envahissantes comme
ça a pu faire récemment on a essayé
d'éradiquer le raisin marron
heureusement nous on fait partie d'une
association qui s'appelle l'APL qui nous
a beaucoup aidés dans un premier temps
pour tout ce qui était reconnaissances
des végétaux parce qu'il a fallu se
former effectivement à la reconnaissance
des endémiques et des indigènes on doit
avoir à peu près 60 espèces de plantes
endémiques et indigènes et en nombre de
plans ça doit faire dans les 4000 plans
à peu près Bénédicte Rodier l'épouse de
Patrick à l'origine du projet nous
explique ces démarches et sa vision sur
l'avenir de la pépinière le Timao j'ai
rencontré en fait monsieur poulbassia
duplilleux donc je lui ai expliqué le
projet flou mais avec quand même une
base donc il m'a demandé en fait de
faire un pré projet avec lui on est
parti voir la boutique de de l'Est là
j'ai rencontré Madame la fin qui était
franchement extraordinaire et m'a tout
donné pour y arriver on me demandant
bien sûr de m'y mettre à fond donc
arrivé à la BGE j'ai eu des aides avec
le plan d'initiative jeune j'ai eu des
crédits avec micro crédit j'ai eu donc
toutes sortes de choses pour avoir donc
les 150 m² de serre plus l'irrigation
sur toute la pépinière j'ai eu 90% de
subventions sur la chaîne mes serres
l'irrigation et le matériel
alligrouicole que nous en fait on a eu
cette subvention l'accueil qui sont
quand même très hautes parce que le
projet était compté comme innovant
et de développement pendant l'avenir
maintenant c'est notre petite plante
endémiques on va peut-être pouvoir
sortir du RSA bientôt et au moins
aujourd'hui je travaille à la maison
on voit notre fille tous les jours on
l'élève ça c'est quelque chose quand
même que dont on avait besoin moi et mon
mari et aujourd'hui je se vois beaucoup
plus sereinement qu'il y a deux ans
quand je suis tombée dans les RSA où je
me suis dit mon Dieu est-ce que je où je
suis arrivé là je suis plus rien je suis
plus personne disons que la production
continue à augmenter qu'on me félicite
tous les jours de faire quelque chose
qui correspond vraiment à ce qu'on
appelle nous le 9 7 4 quoi ça c'est
vraiment à nous quoi à ce rythme là
j'espère bien passé bientôt à 2000
mètres carrés donc il y a une autre
surface que mes beaux-parents m'ont
accordé d'utilisation
et on pourra encore continuer encore
plus haut et espérer avoir d'autres
emplois pour d'autres personnes autre
que mon mari et moi le programme leader
actuel accorde cette année ces derniers
financements après avoir connu un succès
et grandissant la poursuite du
développement rural aura lieu dans le
cadre du programme fait Ader 2014 2020
et s'appuiera sur certains axes
stratégiques notamment sur les systèmes
de production agricole et
agroalimentaire la préservation et la
valorisation des ressources naturelles
et espaces agricoles mais aussi sur le
renforcement de l'attractivité et la
favorisation à la création d'emplois
dans ce cadre un nouvel appel à projet
leader va être lancé en vue de retenir 1
ou déprogrammes de développement des
hauts ainsi que les instances chargés
d'un assurer la gouvernance locale et la
gestion
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais